hey guys dave rubin here that's right
I'm still Dave Rubin this is Rubin
report as you guys know we are making
the move to aura TV they are building
the an unbelievable set right now
so Larry King was nice enough to let me
use his studio today and the reason we
wanted to do some stuff with you guys
today is because I have dr. GAD Sad here
he is professor of marketing at
Concordia University in Montreal Canada
and he's the Research Chair in
evolutionary behavioral sciences and
Darwinian consumption I don't really
don't use a teleprompter but I needed it
for that get how are you very good
yourself good good how first off dad
said how was my pronunciation of your
last name its Arabic am i a desirable
well God is a Hebrew name okay and sad
is an Arabic name but most people can't
say the guttural sound and it just gets
an extended a so yeah I'm sad well I've
heard you do it on your own videos on
YouTube and you don't even do it with
the Gutter Olson because I don't want to
intimidate the viewers with that sound
so a Hebrew first name Arabic last name
that's right oh you must be very
conflicted I'm not I'm not I'm from
Lebanon yeah but of the Jewish faith
okay so the reason that I wanted to
bring you in and the timing of this
really is just perfect is because we
connected sort of in the last year and a
half or so on Twitter we find ourselves
often in the same Twitter wars with
people the atheists and the new atheists
and the far-left and the people on the
right and everyone that's always
battling on Twitter and we're usually on
the same side with rice and really what
started this whole thing was when Sam
Harris was on Real Time with Bill Maher
and he and Ben Affleck and Bill got into
a big fracas so let's take a look at the
clip and then we'll go from there
sure so the other thing we want to talk
about of course is that you and I have
been trying to make the case I think I
have anyway that liberals need to stand
up for liberal principles this is what I
said on last week's show obviously I got
a lot of hate for it but all I'm saying
is that liberal principles like freedom
of speech freedom to practice any
religion you want without fear of
violence freedom to leave a religion
equality for women equality for
minorities including homosexuals these
are a liberal
possible that liberals applaud for but
then when you say in the Muslim world
this is what's lacking then they get
upset yeah yeah well liberals have
really failed on the topic of theocracy
they'll criticize white theocracy
they'll criticize Christians they'll
still get agitated over the abortion
clinic bombing that happened in 1984 but
when when you want to talk about the
treatment of women and homosexuals and
freethinkers and and public
intellectuals in the Muslim world I
would argue that liberals have failed us
and the crucial point of confusion yeah
thank you thank god you're here yeah
well I mean that the crucial point of
confusion is that that we have been sold
this meme of Islamophobia where every
criticism of the doctrine of Islam gets
conflated with bigotry toward Muslims as
people right that is it's intellectually
ridiculous they even it gets through a
whole are you the person who understands
the officially codified doctrine of
Islam you're not you're what oh you
don't say well this is I think any
actually well-educated on this time I'm
asking you I mean you're saying if I
criticize that you're saying that
Islamophobia is not a real thing that if
you're critical of something what's not
a real thing when we do it but equal
well no it's really is I'm not denying
that that certain people are bigoted
against Muslims as people that right and
that's a problem big of you but the why
don't we hope about this it is gross
it's racist it's not it's but it's so
nice oh it's like saying though so Nate
you're shifty Jew
you're not lab solutely not we are
saying you guys are saying if you want
to be liberals believe in liberal
principles like freedom speech like mom
you know we are endowed by our
forefathers of the Nayla bowl a strike
all men are created oh man we have to be
able to criticize bad ideas okay so that
clip goes on for about ten minutes and I
showed you about two minutes right there
and I think Sam hit the point right at
the end that we have to be able to
criticize bad ideas and to me this I've
seen a real schism in people on the left
now I'm obviously on the left I stand
for liberal principles but this schism
and this idea that you can't criticize
ideas without somehow condemning a whole
group of people I know this is a bit
a point of contention for you so can you
walk us through that I don't I don't
think that people have difficulty
criticizing ideas I think it's a
specific idea right so I see it every
day in my exchanges on Facebook if I
criticize some Jewish practice I get
many many likes on Facebook if I
criticize some hick Republican senator
about his position on evolution I get
tons of likes but if I dare criticize
something about Islam I'll give you a
very quick example I put up a clip of a
Iraqi scientist an astronomer who was
arguing that the earth is flat because
it says so in the Quran yeah so I
received of course many of my Facebook
friends are academics I received from a
white sort of guilt-ridden academic from
from California and a note saying well
huh what why are you ganging up on these
folks so she wasn't offended by the fact
that this Iraqi scientist was holding it
astonishingly outrageous view she was
annoyed that I would actually point to
that yeah so why do you think people
have trouble making this distinction
it's very obvious to me as as an
outsider of this I look at I'm Jewish
but I look at the book you could say
whatever you want about the book and all
the awful things that are in the Old
Testament of the New Testament of the
Quran frankly I haven't really read any
of them I don't so they're their books
their ideas why why do people seem
unable to detach those two things
because I think that I think the the
misinformation associated with the idea
that if you criticize Islam in
particular yeah you're bigoted because
Islam is a religion of brown people
right and so therefore they're simply
unable to decouple the criticism of a
set of tenets from the people who may
practice those tenets right so to me
Bill Maher sort of hid the maybe the
bigger point here which is that for
people on the left for liberals we have
to stand up consistently
for liberal principles which is
certainly what I try to do I stand up
for women's rights and gay rights and
freedom of religion and economic
equality and all of those things so is
this where liberals have really failed
and the way they fail is by invoking
cultural and moral relativism right so
who are we to judge that women in some
faraway land their clitorises are being
cut
right who are we to impose our cultural
hegemony on other folks and so this is
how they're able to still be liberal and
yet not criticize these one particular
sets of beliefs by invoking cultural
relativism right so there's a real
disconnect in reality there because in a
in a weird way liberal should be the
most for helping these piece on right
because these are the principles they
believe in so how much of this actually
I really hadn't thought of the status
now but I guess a lot of this we could
sort of blame the footsteps of george w
bush for going into the wrong war where
now there's this feeling in america like
we shouldn't do anything ever because we
did the wrong thing clearly in iraq and
now it's it's a far worse mess than even
before so some of the blame is on us
right but i mean how far do you go back
unfolding history until you find the
villain of your choice right yeah so for
example when we talk about the
israel-palestine issue people are always
able to unfold history until the
starting point that they feel happy
about and then that's the point where we
start the clock right so what was where
should we start the clock on that one on
this llama shoe on israel-palestine okay
yeah well that's that at the whole life
it's a whole other thing if we could get
into it if you want I think the problem
there is that you've got two Abrahamic
religions that hold very very rigid
positions and as long as it's going to
be laden with religion it's never going
to be resolved so in a weird way so what
you're saying is that that liberals
don't want to criticize Islam because
there's this idea that a lot of Islamic
people have brown skin but there are
plenty of moroccan jews you're 11 east
you right there are plenty of Christians
that are Iraqi there's not that many
anymore but so even that in a weird way
you could say that that's actually
bigoted that that that concept is
bigoted how do you as a dark-skinned Jew
how do you feel about that well I
usually am able to get away with a lot
more stuff precisely because I invoke
the fact that I have dark skin the fact
that I'm from the Middle East and I use
this victimology game against the social
justice warriors yeah I basically saying
hey be careful don't you criticize me
because then you'd be engaging it I
refer both aerophobia fascism down
Danny I actually did the privilege score
and I scored off the charts in my non
privilege wow I'm untouchable
you're completely uncool so the next
part of this that I think is
particularly interesting and this is
really where we met because of the
Twitter thing that I referenced earlier
is there has been sort of an endless
onslaught on sam harris since this now
sam is a philosopher i think he's a
neuroscientist at risk i've read some
books he's not a political person per se
he writes a little bit about politics
but not really but there has been this
endless onslaught and I think slandering
and smearing him coming from the left
from people that in some cases I admire
partly some people that I've worked with
I'm talking about from from Glenn
Greenwald who obviously has done great
stuff with the NSA and Reza asked on my
former boss Jiang Kyogre people that are
really distorting his views and I wanted
to show a tweet that I got last night
that I think kind of sums up the whole
things let's take a look at the tweet
okay so this had nothin tweeting about
this this has nothing to do with
anything
then someone tweet does have me question
for Rubin report how it exactly are we
better than Isis if we nuke the Middle
East killing millions of civilians like
Sam Harris suggests and then Sam Harris
later wrote back the person and said you
really believe that I've actually
suggested that okay so that tweet right
there the reason I wanted to use it is
because I feel like it's a perfect
example of how this discussion that
we're talking about has been so far
derailed now of course Sam Harris
doesn't want a nuke the mid the Middle
East
he had one page in his book that's
mostly about philosophy and religion
where he's talking about how in the Cold
War we had you know mutual assurances
basically with Russia because you had
rational actors basically that wouldn't
nuke each other because then they were
afraid they were gonna get new now this
is nothing he never said nuke the Middle
East or any of this stuff but these
people keep implying it
they keep retweeting memes of you know
selectively quotes what do you make of
that I mean these these are pretty
respected people some that I know
personally which is why I struggle with
this so much you know in the battle of
ideologies the people that you want to
go after and not the people who've got
big muscles but the people have big
brains those are so totalitarian
ideologies always go after the
intellectuals first they want to purge
them because they don't want anybody to
counter their narrative and so this is
exactly what happens to guys like sam
harris he has a huge following that
can't be literally beheaded because we
don't live in the Middle East but I
could certainly try my darkness to
behead his reputation I'm going to do
that by engaging in endless
misinformation so that people can
distance himself from him and he's just
a quack he's a he's a war monger he's a
Nazi
he's part of a Zionist conspiracy and
hopefully okay and don't forget me okay
right that's a neocon easy out of
Halliburton yeah and so on and and and
the way I behead him the way I silenced
him is by smearing him right so isn't
that really the crazy part of this when
they're saying well you know sam harris
is in the same neocon group or Bill
Maher's in the same neocon group as Dick
Cheney Bill Maher has never no more
talked about all time he wants our we
have thirty thousand traps or something
in Germany what the hell are they doing
there man this is literally the reverse
of a neocon but these these slurs the
these are slanders right really I mean
is that well these these false
equivalences you are everywhere within
this discourse so for example if you
take some feminists they'll argue that
the bikini is a patriarchal tool of
oppression whereas the burka is a
liberating thing because it removes the
male gaze from the picture right so
while the bikini clad woman is being
visually raped by men once you once you
Don the burqa she is liberated so these
types of equivalences are astonishing
but they're everywhere right now as
backwards as I may think that is I would
say you know what you can believe that
if you want but it should be up to the
woman to decide where in most of those
countries where women are wearing burkas
they don't really have the choice not to
wear of course now I'm more critical at
this point in where I'm at of the left
because I'm part of the left and I want
the left to be better I've long given up
on trying to fix the right right that's
that you know I'm not going to fix the
trash party but I can at least I think
try to change for the better the part
that I'm with so that's why this is so
disappointing what do you make of this
idea that the that the far left is
attacking atheists of all groups of
people it's astonishing I mean what want
it I guess one of the reasons why they
attack the Atheist is because they might
be some of the most vociferous a group
of people that are critical of religion
in general but Aslam in particular and
so to the extent that the progress
don't like criticisms on Islam and to
the extent that many of the most famous
atheists are quite vociferous in their
criticism of Islam and we have to go
after them and I guess this goes back to
what you were saying earlier but they
don't seem to be able to make the
distinction when Bill Maher relentlessly
attacks Christianity nobody calls him a
Christian of right right I mean he made
a documentary where he attacked the big
three religions relentlessly nobody
advanced selectively processing of
information is a big cognitive bias
right so I will only pay attention to
information that supports my position
and that's exactly what the progressives
are doing they're ignoring the endless
times that Bill Maher attacks other
religions yeah but they only tune in
when he criticizes Islam I would bet and
someone can check this for us but I
would bet that Bill Maher has spent far
more time attacking Christianity because
he attacks things in this country far
more than tacking Islam or Judaism or
whatever what do you make of how much
hatred there seems to be towards
atheists at the moment because I see all
these polls and on the show many times
we've done how atheists are the most
underrepresented group in everything
Barney Frank who was in Congress for
30-something years was able to come out
as gay m80s but not as an atheist until
he retired from Congress right what do
you make of this because if he is hold
no power have not our people are atheist
killing people that I don't know about
right my feeling is that there is a
coupling of atheism and immorality in
the minds of most people
so most people believe that it doesn't
matter which religion you follow as long
as you are religious then you somehow
have a moral compass by which you live
your life by however atheists go around
beheading puppies and then raping them
in the minds of those folks and so an
atheist is not to be trusted
because how elsewhere can he get his
morality if it's not from some Bronze
Age book right so I think what you just
told me is that it's complete nonsense
it is complete loss I mean it could it
be anything other than that right I mean
because atheists simply aren't doing any
of exaust things no it's complete lunacy
political correctness oh yeah which i
think is completely running rampant
across America right and I live within
it as an academic academic so I swim in
it alright so you know all right so
let's start there there so to the
college part of this you know Jerry
Seinfeld about a month ago Jerry cycled
who's the most 8 political comics I know
everything
Oh Jerry Seinfeld I don't know any of
his political beliefs I have no idea if
he's for abortion for the death penalty
nobody has any idea what he thinks he
now is saying that college campuses have
gone to politically correct politically
correct Chris Rock has backed him on
this you know a whole bunch of comedians
have said this what is going on on
college campus I'll give you a powerful
personal anecdote last year I gave a
talk at Wellesley College in all women's
college about the thought police and how
it regulates the free exchange of ideas
after my lecture a student came up to me
and said I don't think there's anything
wrong with the idea of a professor at
the start of class polling a hundred
students about how you should address
them so even though for example Dave
Rubin is my student I clearly see you as
a male at the start of every lecture I
should say do you do you gender identify
as male or female because that will
deter so I looked at her and in true
astonishment I said you really see this
as a viable way by which society would
be organized where every single time we
interact we should first preempt any any
greeting with what do yourself identify
as and she said absolutely because that
way you wouldn't be hurting anybody by
placing them in the wrong category yeah
that's astonishing right okay so what's
the most dangerous part of that because
to me it seems like let's say you went
ahead and did that you taught this class
exactly as sort of the social justice
warriors would want you to teach it well
the world doesn't operate like that
right so then aren't you actually then
setting up these kids these college kids
for a huge awakening where the day they
graduate college but they're not well
trained to face that real world right
right
they are so tentative and the way they
express themselves right they're so
afraid to step outside the herd I mean
if you look at intellectual diversity on
campuses which is very much related to
what we're talking about it's
breathtaking right look I'm Canadian so
I don't care Republican or Democrat I
don't have a dog in that fight right but
there are stopping I gotta get this
straight Jew Arab Canadian man 80s
atheist and brown skin oh my you've got
a lot you really do have a lot all right
sorry yeah so so that there were studies
that were done looking
at the political affiliations of
professors at major American
universities whether they're Republican
or Democrats and the numbers are just
astonishing and they get worse and worse
in terms of the ratio as a function of
the softness of the field sort of in the
humanities and sociology and Gender
Studies it's something like forty one
forty four to one
the ratio of now for some issues
political political lens doesn't matter
but for others is the death penalty
appropriate what should be our fiscal
policy should we be should we be foreign
policy interventionist well your
political if lens affects these
discussions and to have all academia
being represented by one side of the
political spectrum is horrifying so what
do we do about that I mean even though I
may in most cases agree with that end of
academia not certainly not the political
correct side but I might agree with him
philosophically on a lot of the points
how do you balance that out what so
Thomas solo who's a very famous
conservative economist said I'm going to
botch the exact quote he said
intellectual diversity is diversity on
campuses is great as long as its sexual
orientation diversity ethnic diversity
racial diversity but the one diversity
that should really matter intellectual
diversity we condemn it well what we
need to do is use not which is thought
exactly and what we need to was to find
ways to create greater diversity on
campuses to allow both sides of any
position to speak yeah do you think a
lot of this has to do with the way our
culture has changed in the last couple
years like where you can't bully a kid
now I'm not for bullying of course but
that this concept where we keep making
everything that no one can ever be
offended by anything you know they took
after the Confederate flag after the
shooting in Charleston
now they took Dukes of Hazard off
television do exact that they were not
somehow southern white supremacist you
know I mean but they they took that off
television okay I'm not going to defend
Cosby who is one of my comedy heroes
growing up but they took the cosby show
up there like we're starting to censor
ourselves I think in a way that's going
to lead to everything you know every
time I watch Seinfeld now every episode
think in 10 years they're going to say
this was racist and massage literally
every single episode salon did a piece a
couple weeks ago about troublesome
episodes of Seinfeld what do we do to
combat that
well progressives pray at the altar they
sell flagellate at the altar of non
offense I mean that's that's their their
motto we need to find a way to break
through the stop police I might give you
an example when I used to be a very
competitive soccer player if I were to
today look at the trash-talking that
went on the soccer fields between
players which is part of the ritual then
everybody would be arrested today
everybody would be sent to hate speech
time again right because you mean cuz of
racist stuff in homophobic siman
everything off under exactly yeah guess
what I heard camel jockey growing up
playing soccer and I live to to love
again yeah right I mean it's called life
grow a parent so so how do we what do we
do about that because that I really like
what do we do to get to grow a pair for
the country or for Canada or well I mean
there are many different ways for
example the culture of narcissism is
certainly not helping the kids the
culture of entitlement right everybody
should get an a-plus everybody should
get a medal everybody should get a
trophy so there there's several
different movements that have for lack
of a better word pacified the West
you're not gonna be happy with you for
that that's okay bruh
alright let's talk a little bit about
some of the some of the machinations I
suppose of things that are going on on
college trigger warnings and some of
these other things so you were certain
you sort of talked about this a little
bit earlier safe spaces yes for safe
space safe spaces is a place where I can
go so that I'm protected from things
that might make me go into a fetal
position and suck my thumb to give me
one for example well why would you go to
a safe why would someone in college go
to it yeah maybe there's going to be a
speaker who's going to talk something
about pro-israel and I might be a
student who is very much against Israel
and so that makes me feel very
threatened at the University of Michigan
they wanted to simply show was it was a
called sniper what was it the movie
called and that made a lot of the
students feel very unsafe simply because
that movie
is going to be shown on campus yeah it's
astonishing do you remember when Bill
Maher was being asked to give the
commencement speech at Berkeley Berkeley
which is the bastion the home of free
speech in America and some of the kids
there didn't want him to do it he ended
up doing it but he had a guest I forget
her name I was actually in the audience
that episode he had a guest who said
that he shouldn't do it because he's
against free speech meanwhile she's on
her she's on his show using her right to
free speech so there's there really is
like a cognitive disconnect there he's
absolutely I wrote an article where I
haven't done posts where I talked about
trigger warnings and I listed all of the
different concepts that necessitate
trigger warnings pretty much everything
under the Sun I mean literally life
requires a trigger warning yeah is this
why everyone's medicated
pretty much right I think you're onto
something you know I do think there is a
connection between you know if you do
all this stuff right and you give every
everyone knows the trigger warnings you
give them safe spaces you don't let them
hear from contrarian views and all this
stuff then you throw them out in the
world where none of this stuff is real
because you get out to the world and
it's pretty shitty and you know you're
gonna have a boss that might be sexist
or a neighbor that might be homophobic
that is why then everyone medicate right
because then they're not given the tools
to deal in reality life I agree how's
that behavioral sciences that's that's a
pretty nice pop psychology very nice I
thought that was pretty good do you
think the Internet is helping or or
hurting I think it'll I mean I think to
the extent that the internet serves as a
vehicle for meme propagation people can
get their message out otherwise they
might have difficulty doing so so in
that sense it's great right the problem
is that some of the ones who hurled the
greatest amount of venom are the people
who really are against the free exchange
of ideas so the social justice warriors
that come after guys luckily I've
actually been free of most of these guys
maybe because I'm quite reason than my
positions may be hopefully but make sure
they come after their stores and some of
my people say they don't very good yeah
so I think that on average is a bit of
both good in that you allow people to
express themselves bad and that there is
one camp of folks that is a lot more
vested in shutting down free exchange so
is that the challenge then of the
atheist community or the secular
community or the rational community is
that we don't yell as loud right so how
do we then line up in a way versus
versus the trolls versus the angry mob
how do you get sane people to band
together well at the very least and I
often admonish my academic colleagues
for this who don't participate in this
in this great public discourse right
they're very interested in doing their
very narrow research but yet they're shy
away from talking about these bigger
issues even though they're professors I
mean you're all about meme propagation
if you're a professor yeah and so what I
would do at least what I do in my
limited sphere of influence is to try to
get my colleagues to weigh in on these
issues so that we could have academics
Wayne and not just the trolls yeah does
that work very well I haven't been very
successful because most are terrified of
their shadows yeah so what does that say
then that it's not just I guess it's
coming from every angle right it's
coming from politicians and it's coming
from the media people and it's coming
from the professors not just well I
would add I would add cowardice as part
of the seven deadly sins I would make it
eight deadly sins and out cowardice it's
I'm astonished at how cowardly most
people are there if and and I even get
people come to me and say you know I
mean you do great science you're you're
a known scientist why do you weigh in on
these issues because I can't help it
because it's I feel that it's my job to
weigh in on issues that are nonsensical
like the ones we discussed earlier yeah
that's part of my job description yeah
you know I feel the same way actually
sometimes I think when I'm when I'm
tweeting about this stuff or when I'm
writing about it or whatever it is I
think I wish I didn't have to talk about
this stuff you know in a weird way
because it's so obvious to me you know
that the atheists and the secular is
that we're on the right side of letting
everyone I want to treat everyone as
shitty as everyone else they wouldn't be
treated as well as everyone else you
know I mean I don't want to be treated
better than anyone or worse just treat
me the same shitty way you treat
everybody else a lot of times when I'm
in New York City that's what I think
like everyone if there's every race
there there's every color there's every
ethnicity everything and it's like
everyone hates each other but no one's
killing anybody pretty much is that fun
any any final thoughts this I mean I
could talk to you all day well hopefully
I'll be back again soon
I wanted to congratulate you on your
move to this network okay great to meet
you in person and we're not Twitter
works right we've done this we've never
spoken more than 140 characters and yet
I feel like I know you're very well yeah
there you go
all right well you guys can check out
dad's YouTube page will annotate to it
so there should be something if you're
watching on YouTube right over here and
I thank you very much and yeah this is
just the beginning of the types of stuff
we're going to be doing now that we're
on our TV the new set is coming and the
show will officially launch I think it's
the second week in September but I also
check with my lawyers thanks for
watching everybody